en momentos en que la comunidad
internacional saluda la eventual llegada
al mercado de prometedoras vacunas las
autoridades sanitarias africanas alertan
que el continente podría sufrir las
desastrosas consecuencias de esta
carrera liderada por los países ricos
sabemos que los países africanos están
inquietos y esperamos que la reserva de
millones de dosis de vacunas por los
países ricos no les suponga una
desventaja para el acceso a los
tratamientos y software el continente
todavía no está listo para desplegar una
campaña de vacunación a gran escala los
principales obstáculos el costo y la
logística de las operaciones el acceso a
1,5 millones de dosis estimadas para
vacunar al 60% de la población africana
necesitaría una inversión de más de 55
billones de dólares un coste estimado
que corresponde solamente a la compra de
las vacunas a lo que habría que sumar el
precio del material almacenamiento y
distribución y que podría elevarse
considerablemente si fuera necesaria una
segunda campaña de vacunación
que disponemos de vacunas que son
efectivas o que al menos parecen serlo y
que tenemos la previsión de
distribuirlas de manera masiva no se
debería frenar la investigación y el
desarrollo de nuevas vacunas todavía no
sabemos cuánto tiempo durará la
inmunidad de estas vacunas que están por
llegar a menos la semana pasada el
número de casos de coronavirus
confirmados en áfrica superó los 2
millones y la oms advirtió que el
continente se dirige hacia una segunda
ola de infecciones en este momento se
han efectuado alrededor de 21 millones
de test en el continente africano que
cuenta con más de 1300 millones de
habitantes